now we're back to big guys javon kinlaw
south carolina defensive lineman all six
foot five 324 pounds of him here with us
javon how are you buddy i'm pretty good
can't complain what do you think of this
what do you think of this
blessed just blessed to be here
uh well did you feel that way when you
were sitting in the medical room waiting
to be poked and prodded that's got i i
could not do it i couldn't sit still for
five minutes waiting for my number to be
called to be to be checked out by the
doctor it was a long process but it was
worth it at the end of the day so
how many teams have you talked to so far
uh at least over 20
at least
what's the what we hear every year
usually after the combine the weirdest
question that a guy gets and different
things come up what's the strangest
question or tactic that was used to try
to get you to maybe uh let your guard
down and and not be
as prepared as you would be to answer
the questions
uh i haven't really been getting a lot
of those questions you know they've been
pretty straightforward with me so
is there any coach or gm that when you
walked into the room you were like wow i
can't believe i'm in here with this guy
um
not really honestly i just
i just feel like that way with everybody
you know i'm just blessed to be sitting
here with you like i'm like wow
you don't know me very well i don't you
won't feel that way in 10 minutes i
don't but
a couple years ago like i never even
thought like i would be here yeah i mean
you've got a great story a great back
story and it shows
that you've got the talent you've got
the character and you've got the
personality to get through adversity
that most people don't have to ever get
through and most people couldn't get
through what's the biggest lesson you've
learned through your journey very unique
very rare journey to get from where you
were to where you are now um you just
can't ever give up on yourself you know
because there's gonna be times where
you're not gonna
see the light or you're not gonna really
understand where you at in your life you
know but you just gotta see it all the
way through you know whatever you're
doing you just gotta finish it see it
all the way through man cuz you never
know what's at the end of the tunnel
waiting on you you know what i'm saying
javon what was the lowest point for you
what was the moment where you're like i
can't believe it can't get any worse for
me than this um
the lowest point for me was as a child
you know but again i didn't see it that
way but now i'm seeing it you know that
was the lowest point for me like living
in a basement so
having to use the bathroom outside that
type of stuff so when did you realize
that you had the kind of skill that
could propel you to the nfl
right not to
my senior year honestly
well seeing it like
but
a lot of people always tell me you know
man if you just keep stick with it you
got a chance to do something special but
for me
it didn't really
manifest until like my junior senior
year so who are the people around you
that maybe helped you realize and and
and have the discipline you needed to
get the most out of the god-given
abilities you have uh for one for
starters my juco d-line coach coach
anthony maddox um he always pounded that
in my head you know um but when i got to
south carolina like coach muschamp
and every other coach that was there
they always telling me the same stuff
like man you got a chance to do
something special
you know you got a special ability to
you got things that other people don't
got you know you do things that other
people just can't physically do so
when did you
uh go through your your growth spurt to
get to 6'5 324 how old were you um well
in like 8th grade i probably was like 6
foot going from from eighth grade to
ninth grade i went from like six foot to
maybe
like six two six three then my sophomore
like not sophomore but 10th grade yeah i
went from like six three to six five and
then i stopped growing after that so do
you have to fight to keep your work on
you gotta really make yourself i mean
your weight on to to eat to stay at 324
i eat a lot so i mean it's not really
hard yeah i i gain and lose weight fast
so
um who is the player that when you're
out on the nfl field you're going to
look out there and you're going to see
him you're going to say i can't believe
i'm out here with this guy
um
all right if i was playing probably if i
was playing next to him donald or chris
jones or fletcher cox somebody like that
man it would be crazy i'd be like man i
just was watching this guy you know so
you're one of the only ones that didn't
say tom brady
nah tom brady don't play my position
so you get to chase tom brady yeah you
may get to knock tom brady on the ground
yeah but i don't get to play next to tom
no i know well and you know what chris
jones says to tom brady when he knocks
him on the ground he calls him an old
man he is old enough
well hey javon it's great to visit with
you i know you got a busy week we
appreciate you giving us some of your
time and really you can read up on javon
kinlaw look it's an inspiring story
you've come a long way man and and we
are proud of what you've done and we
look forward to seeing what you do in
the national football league we're
rooting for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports